10 بلديات في المجموعه تقطنها اغلبيه
صربيه بقيه مصدر الصداع لكوسوفه الا ان
خريطه طريق اوروبيه جاءت عامه 2013 بحلا
واقعي اقنع جميع الاطراف الخطه كانت تهدف
لاعطاء البلديات التي تسكنها الاغلبيه
حريه تشكيل كيان موحد يتمتع بحريه اداره
شؤونه الاداريه والثقافيه امر لم يحصل
طبعا ممثل الاقليه الصربيه استنكروا تجاهل
الحكومه للاتفاق وكحل اخير لجا المنتخبون
في البلديات الصربيه نهايه العام الماضي
الى الاستقاله من اجل خلق فراغ دستوري
كانت هذه خطوه اولى ثم جاءت دور اعلى
السكان الذين قاطعوا الانتخابات نسبه
المشاركه لم تتعدى 3% ورغم ذلك اعتبرت
الحكومه ان الانتخابات شرعيه وعينت رؤساء
بلديات البانيين في بلداتنا الصربيه وهنا
خرجت الامور عن السيط ره ومن حدود كوسوفو
ايضا
[موسيقى]
ازمته كوسوفو والاقليات الصربيه فيها لم
تحل منذ سنوات والسبب ليس مقتصرا على
تعقيد الازمه بل لانها تختصر الصراع
العالمي بين الشرق والغرب روسيا تربطها
علاقات تاريخيه بالصربيا ورفضت بشده قصف
الناتو الذي انهى سياده صربيا على كسوف
وهي الان تدعم كل الاقليات الصربيه في
البوسنه وكوسوفو بشكل مباشر
هناك انفجار كبير في وسط اوروبا في نفس
المكان الذي شن فيه النيتو عام
1999 عدوانا على يوزلافيا منتهكا جميع
مبادئ اتفاقيه السينكي وغيرها من وثائق
منظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا الوضع
مقلق لكن الغرب يستعمل نفس الاساليب مع كل
من يرغب في انشاء سياسه مستقله
يرجعه البعض دعم موسكو للاقليات الصربيه
في البلقان الى اسباب دينيه وثقافيه لكن
الحرب في اوكرانيا جعلت صربيا تبتعد عن
حلمها في الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي حسب
بروكسل والسبب رفضها المشاركه في العقوبات
الغربيه المفروض على روسيا دعم الصربيا
لروسيا رافقه دعم شعبي من كل صرب البلقان
للعمليات العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لكن هناك اسباب اخرى اكثر براجمتيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات